أجنبي سمعنا لأول مرة أننا سنزور
بنك الدماغ في الدنمارك
، ولا بد لي من الاعتراف بأن هذا هو أكثر ما كان يدور
في ذهني وهذا هو المكان الذي نحتفظ
فيه بنصفي الكرة الأرضية المجمدة.
أدمغة udensa
جنبًا إلى جنب مع بعض الآلاف من
الأدمغة التي تم التبرع بها هنا
لبنك الدماغ الحديث الوحيد في الدنمارك
حيث يدرسون مجموعة متنوعة من الاضطرابات
بما في ذلك الأمراض النفسية ،
لذلك إذا كنت تجري
دراسات تشخيصية جزيئية ، فهل تستخرج
أجزاء صغيرة من المواد نعم
واليوم هو يفحص دماغًا كاملاً
من بنك الدماغ الحديث لم يتم
لمسه أو حثه بعد ،
سأعرضه لك تمامًا كما رأيناها لأول مرة
ولكني أريد أن أحذرك لأن هذا
ليس شيئًا
اعتاد عليه دماغ الإنسان  ترى نفسها كما يمكنك أن
ترى كيف يبدو
رائعًا ، فهذه هي مياه Jason ، لذا فهذه هي الطريقة التي تبدو بها [موسيقى] هذه مجرد نظرة رائعة على
الدماغ الذي تنظر إليه  نانوغرام في الجانب الأيسر
من الدماغ أول الجبهة الأمامية والخلفية
الفص القذالي الفص
الصدغي الفص الجداري
نفسه على الجانب الآخر ،
اسمحوا لي أن أريكم شيئًا قليلًا جدًا من
الناس يرون أن
هذا هو قاعدة الدماغ وهذا
هو جذع الدماغ
الذي  يمكن القول إنه أكثر العقارات قيمة
في الدماغ ، فهو يتحكم في
كل ما تفعله دون التفكير في
أنك تتنفس معدل ضربات قلبك ،
وهناك شيء آخر يجب على ميخيل أن
يُظهر لي شيئًا لم
أره في الواقع أولاً.
يجب أن يبدو الدماغ الطبيعي كما لو كنت ترى
النوع الطبيعي من طيات الدماغ
والأهم من ذلك أنك ترى
منطقة المادة البيضاء هذه في منتصف
الدماغ هنا وهذا طبيعي وهذا ما
يجب أن يبدو عليه ولكن إذا أتيت إلى
هنا سترى  تلك المناطق نفسها من
الدماغ في الفص الأمامي
حيث تم تدمير منطقة المادة البيضاء على
جانبي الدماغ ، وضع شخص ما
أداة هناك يمكنك رؤيتها حتى في
المكان الذي وضعوا فيه الأداة و
لقد كشطوا نوعًا ما
المادة البيضاء على كلا الجانبين الأيمن والأيسر ،
ورؤيتها هنا أيضًا ، وهذا هو ما
يبدو عليه استئصال الفصوص
الخارجية ،
دعني أكون واضحًا بشأن شيء
أرى أن هذا ليس لقيمة الصدمة ، فإن
شق الفص جزء لا يتجزأ من
التاريخ النفسي للدنمارك خلال
الفترة التي كانت تجري فيها مجموعة الدماغ ،
ورد أن الدنمارك قامت بإجراء عمليات جراحية لفصص الفصوص
للفرد أكثر من أي دولة أخرى في
العالم